nordrhein westfalen heute morgen
erftstadt eine kraterlandschaft die flut
reist mit was ihr im weg steht auch
ganze häuser im aartal rheinland pfalz
ist das wasser weg zurück geblieben ist
die zerstörung rettungskräfte aus ganz
deutschland sind im dauereinsatz
unermüdlich um den menschen zu helfen
die fast alles verloren haben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend in allen
schon jetzt danke für ihr interesse
norbert lehmann ist auch dabei für den
sport genannt eigentlich könne man nur
noch weinen sagt malu dreyer
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
mehr als 100 menschen sind in den
hochwassergebieten ums leben gekommen
hunderte werden noch vermisst
aber die lage ist unübersichtlich auch
weil mobilfunk netze gestört sind weite
teile von nordrhein westfalen und
rheinland pfalz sind von dem jahrhundert
hochwasser betroffen
wir berichten aus irrel im kreis bitburg
prüm wo freiwillige helfer und thw
gemeinsam den betroffenen helfen
besonders schwer hat es den kreis
ahrweiler erwischt vor allem das dorf
schuld zunächst schauen wir aber nach
erftstadt in nordrhein westfalen dort wo
in der nacht noch häuser standen klaffen
jetzt riesige erdlöcher heiko rams
berichtet die flutwelle kam heute am
frühen morgen und riss alles mit
erftstadt der ortsteil blässe die
bewohner ahnten nichts als der damm
einer nahe gelegenen kiesgrube brach
meter hoch schoss das wasser durch die
engen straßen des ortes danach
unterspülte die nahe erst mehrere häuser
die daraufhin zusammenbrachen
martin sporn besaß einen reiterhof der
jetzt in einem loch verschwunden ist
hinter ihm liegen dramatische stunden
seine frau war verschollen
irgendwann haben wir uns das leben aus
den augen verloren
dann war sie aber er hat ja keiner mehr
handy keiner telefon man konnte sich
nicht mehr verständigen und man konnte
nicht zueinander kommen deswegen wusste
keiner wo ist wer und das war ganz
furchtbar unter lebensgefahr führt und
seine frau und er zuvor gemeinsam mit
nachbarn die pferde vom hof in
sicherheit in der zeit stürzten weitere
teile seines hofes in die grube wir
haben hier viele viele pferde das durch
einen meter fünfzig hohes wasser
evakuiert es ist 48 stunden kampf von
wirklich ganz vielen menschen die uns
geholfen haben die uns wahnsinnig
unterstützt haben
die natur ist trotzdem stärker der den
kampf gewonnen und so haben viele
menschen aus erftstadt blessem ihre
existenz verloren polen im bungalow und
der großteil steht im keller und damit
ist auch mein ganzes hab und gut weg
moment kann man einfach nur nur weil man
gar nicht begreifen wassermassen
innerhalb von einer
halben stunde sah manchmal gekommen sind
wir haben kein gast mehr kein hofberg
keller bis unterkante alles voll
die stadt erftstadt rechnet mit
todesopfern seien über 280 menschen
gerettet worden darunter auch die frau
vom martin sporn nach 20 stunden suche
hat er sie wieder gefunden
alexander hettich ist in erbstadt
alexander warum weiß man immer noch
nichts genaueres über die zahl der opfer
ja wenn man dann dem krater rand
gestanden hat wie ich bis vor einer
halben stunde dann hat man schnell eine
vorstellung davon dass die behörden das
gar nicht wissen können das ist eine
riesige grube dagegen autos drin da
liegen trümmer drin da liegen teile von
häusern drin und möglicherweise auch
opfer ich habe eben noch mit dem landrat
sprechen können bis jetzt ist kein
einziges opfer aus diesem krater heraus
bestätigt und dann geht aber einfach
davon aus es muss opfer geben weil die
verwüstungen dort so groß sind wir sind
jetzt vor wenigen minuten auch aus dem
ort verwiesen worden so wie alle
menschen aus blättern auch die anwohner
der grund ist sorge wegen vandalismus
und plünderern
aber auch die statik der häuser steht
nach wie vor in frage gerade am krater
rand habe ich heute noch sehen können
wie teile der autobahn lärmschutzwände
in die erft gestürzt sind der ganze
boden ist instabil
da fragt man sich auch wie viele häuser
können da stehen bleiben wie viele
häuser werden nachträglich noch für
unbewohnbar erklärt also für die
anwohner geht das drama weiter viele
werden heute in notunterkünften schlafen
müssen oder bei freunden und niemand
weiß wie lange das geht und welche
zukunft dieser teil des heims noch hat
auch das kann niemand sagen
eindrücke aus erftstadt blessin vielen
dank alexander hettich nach rheinland
pfalz und dort in den kreis ahrweiler
die behörden rechnen damit dass entlang
des flusses a mehr als 100 häuser massiv
beschädigt oder komplett zerstört sind
im dorf schuld wird immer mehr das
ausmaß der katastrophe von mittwochnacht
sichtbar
maria geiger berichtet
schuld an der a 2 tage nach der
katastrophe nacht viele häuser sind
unbewohnbar
etliche einsturzgefährdet für die 700
menschen hier ist nichts mehr wie vorher
was ihnen passiert ist können sie immer
noch kaum fassen
im minuten-takt kann man wirklich sagen
minutentakt zehn zentimeter mehr
mein schwager hat noch versucht hier
autos zu retten ist noch gerade
herausgekommen ist mein auto runter
geschwemmt worden
vor allen dingen ist kein strom gas kein
wasser da ist nichts mehr da kein
telefon kein handy nichts geht mehr
also die laut brauchen
die aufräumarbeiten laufen durch die
zerstörten straßen und brücken ist
schuld jedoch nur schwer zugänglich und
das gilt für viele orte im landkreis
ahrweiler
viele menschen warten noch auf hilfe in
altenahr müssen 100 personen aus einem
altenheim evakuiert werden nur mit
hubschraubern und kleinen fahrzeugen
kommen die rettungskräfte zu ihnen durch
und transportieren sie einzeln zu einer
sammelstelle
dort warten lastwagen um die geretteten
weiterzutransportieren die tragödien im
katastrophengebiet sind zahllos in sind
sich überflutete das wasser dieses
wohnheim für menschen mit geistiger
behinderung es stieg rasend schnell
mitten in der nacht für zwölf personen
wurde das erdgeschoss zur tödlichen
falle
wir haben einen mann retten können der
hängt an der wand und schrie und hat
gerufen ich will nicht sterben hilfe ich
kann die schwimmen und so weiter und wir
haben diesen mann wirklich drei stunden
unterstützt indem er gesagt halte ich
fest wir haben angerufen die kommen
sofort erwiesen rettungsdienst kommt usw
und er ist gerettet worden und die
anderen halt nicht die waren
eingeschlossen
die rettungskräfte werden immer mehr
leichen aus trümmern und schlamm in
deren transportiert die bundeswehr die
toten ab im landkreis ahrweiler werden
noch hunderte menschen vermisst viele
werden einfach nicht zu erreichen sein
weil das mobilfunknetz nur sehr schlecht
funktioniert doch die zahl der opfer
wird im schwer zerstörten landkreis
wahrscheinlich weiter steigen womit er
ihren ist vor ort in schuld wie gehen
die menschen mit dieser situation jetzt
um nun vor allem versuchen sich zurzeit
gegenseitig zu helfen das fängt an bei
hotels die hier kostenfrei zimmer zur
verfügung stellen für menschen die ihr
zuhause verloren haben oder zur zeit zur
zeit nicht nach hause zurück können das
mobilfunk netz funktioniert ja auch
immer noch nicht richtig und was wir
hier in einem nachbarort gesehen haben
in adenau da gibt es offensichtlich eine
firma die hat ein funktionierendes wlan
und die hat das passwort für dieses wlan
schlichtweg an die fensterscheibe
gekicke geklebt mit dem hinweis loggt
euch hier ein
hier könnt ihr ins internet und
zumindest euren familien schreiben wie
es euch zur zeit geht was bei diesen
bildern der zerstörung aus schuld kaum
zu glauben ist
dort gab es keine toten wie wurden die
menschen gewarnt ich habe darüber mit
der einsatzleitung der feuerwehr
gesprochen die menschen wurden gewarnt
über zb cut wann die app vor dem
unwetter während des unwetters und dann
auch als sich das hochwasser abzeichnete
auch darüber habe ich mit den menschen
hier gesprochen viele haben gesagt app
hin oder her
sie wussten von dem unwetter darüber
wurde ja auch berichtet aber im grunde
konnte man sich darauf nicht richtig
vorbereiten jedenfalls nicht auf diese
intensität das wasser stieg so schnell
die regenmassen waren so unglaublich
groß da haben auch die warnungen nichts
geholfen
auf diese situation auf dieses ausmaß
konnte man sich im vorfeld einfach nicht
einstellen
dankeschön noch schuld probiert er ihn
war das schauen wir in die südeifel auch
hier hat das wasser den menschen
buchstäblich den boden unter den füßen
weggezogen
die sonst so harmlose prüm hat den ort
irrel nahezu verschluckt war zu einem
reißenden fluss angeschwollen
nur langsam findet sie den weg zurück in
ihr bett auch das technische hilfswerk
packt beim aufräumen jetzt mit an
susanne gelhard war dabei im eifeldorf
irrel an der pram sind die 2000
einwohner an hochwasser gewöhnt aber
nicht dann so etwas
das ist zerstörung tour sagen sie
innerhalb nur weniger stunden
meine eltern sind auch oben gewesen
deswegen sind wir hier geblieben und ich
hab dann geholt was ich noch greifen
greifen konnte und bin da oben gegangen
und dann gab sie auch kein rauskommen
mehr die strömung war war auch viel zu
stark hier direkt am flussufer will kaum
eine versicherung das risiko tragen
für viele ist das der ruin
so sei ihre gestern aus abgeschnitten
durch das kleine flüsschen freunden
inzwischen ist das wasser leicht
zurückgegangen
zum glück kam keiner ums leben wird
keiner vermisst auch von den behörden
rüsten de dass es schlimm kommt es wurde
auch so gemeldet wir haben zum glück
wirklich rechtzeitig evakuiert wir haben
die sirene laufen lassen mehrmals haben
dann rund sind rund gefahren durchsagen
gemacht
aber mit solchen wassermassen hat
niemand gerechnet
noch immer kein trinkwasser kein strom
kein internet doch die hilfsbereitschaft
ist riesig kollegen familie freunde
kommen von überall her
mich überzeugt er die solidarität weil
hier so viele helfen die dringend
schmieren belegte brötchen das erwartung
ist wirklich gänsehaut bekomme seit
heute morgen ist die räumungs gruppe des
thw vor ort unterstützt von verbänden
aus dem ganzen land ist die freiwillige
feuerwehr seit über 50 stunden nonstop
im einsatz hier wird die hilfe
koordiniert wir haben also sehr viele
orte den abgeschnitten sind wo auch nur
wenige fahrzeuge zum beispiel von der
bundeswehr hinkommen um die leute dort
zu versorgen
in ihre hoffen sie jetzt auf
unbürokratische finanzielle hilfe wir
versuchen natürlich an die hilfen
heranzukommen
nur wenn ich die summen höher ist das
natürlich bei dem maß an zerstörung und
in verschiedenen vielen dörfern hier in
der eifel
ein betrag den man unter umständen daher
aufstocken muss und noch ist die ganze
zerstörung bei weitem nicht sichtbar
sie haben's gehört die not der menschen
hat eine welle der hilfsbereitschaft
ausgelöst hier am nürburgring werden
sachspenden gesammelt kleidung schuhe
spielzeug
innerhalb weniger stunden war das lager
voll
jetzt geht's ans sortieren und verteilen
an die die dringend unterstützung
brauchen anselm stern berichtet zerstört
haben die fluten diesen supermarkt und
damit die wirtschaftliche existenz von
danny preller fast sein ganzes
berufsleben lang hat er hier gearbeitet
in hagen nordrhein-westfalen seien markt
jetzt voller schlamm ob er etwas bekommt
von der versicherung wenn ja wie viel
weiß er nicht dass das herz zerbricht
sie steckt herzblut drin also mit meiner
familie aufgebaut nur ein betroffener
von so vielen die dringend hilfe
brauchen hilfe die jetzt immer weiter an
läuft die bundeswehr im einsatz in den
katastrophengebieten panzer in den
hochwasser trümmern wegräumen aufräumen
nach der flut
es war schon sehr dramatisch hier
fahrzeuge am rand die hier völlig
zerstört waren leute die hier
verzweifelt an der straße stand und uns
um hilfe gebeten haben dass wir die
keller leer pumpen
mehr als 800 soldatinnen und soldaten
sind unterwegs in nordrhein-westfalen
und rheinland-pfalz militärischer
katastrophenalarm wurde ausgelöst heißt
die einsatzkräfte vor ort können mehr
und schneller entscheiden
schnell haben auch andere bundesländer
hilfe losgeschickt aus hamburg zb kommen
boote aus thüringen trinkwasseranlagen
solidarität im land am mittag äußert
sich der bundespräsident in der stunde
der not steht unser land zusammen
ich danke den professionellen
helferinnen und helfern von feuerwehr
polizei thw rotem kreuz bundeswehr und
anderen die leben gerettet haben und
unermüdlich immer noch im einsatz sind
ich möchte den hinterbliebenen meine
anteilnahme
spreche nicht in den gedanken bei ihnen
ihr schicksal trifft mich ins herz die
hoffnung auf hilfe dürfe nicht
enttäuscht werden so steinmeier
die menschen in den flut regionen
müssten langfristig unterstützt werden
wenn sie den opfern der flut helfen
wollen das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe hat ein spendenkonto
eingerichtet stichwort zdf hochwasser
deutschland die iban lautet de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 8
190 hilfe für die opfer der flut hat die
bundesregierung versprochen schnell soll
es gehen um die not der betroffenen zu
lindern
am mittwoch ist das thema im kabinett
die politik und die flut klaus brodbeck
berichtet wo auch immer nur langsam
gewinnt die politik so etwas wie einen
groben überblick über die folgen der
katastrophe
es klingt nicht gut das leid nimmt zu in
rheinland pfalz und unseren gedanken
zins fest bei den menschen die alles
verloren haben wir haben zur stunde 60
tote zu beklagen
und es ist zu befürchten dass die zahl
noch weiter ansteigen wird
23 städte und landkreise sind betroffen
alleine in nrw
der ministerpräsident spricht von einer
flut historischen ausmaßes wir werden
häuser reparieren brücken wieder
aufbauen verkehrswege wieder instand
setzen
aber die menschen leben die in den
fluten verloren gegangen sind sind
unersetzbar schon jetzt absehbar
naturkatastrophen werden sich häufen
experten warnen davor seit jahren
wir werden nicht mehr alle katastrophen
verhindert können wir können nur
versuchen da versuchen uns möglichst gut
anzupassen und da jetzt alle maßnahmen
zu ergreifen die kanzlerkandidatin der
grünen spricht von einer dreifachen
nationalen herausforderung akute hilfe
zu leisten um menschen zu retten
um ihn zu helfen die alles verloren
haben zwei risikovorsorge zu treffen
anpassungsmaßnahmen zu treffen weil
extremwetterereignisse bedingt durch den
klimawandel zu nehmen werden und
drittens müssen wir beim klimaschutz
maßnahmen jetzt wirklich einen oben
drauf satteln damit wir für die nächsten
jahre besser gerüstet sind noch besteht
einigkeit im entsetzen über die
katastrophe über konsequenzen aber
könnte bald gestritten werden
die unwetter kennen keine grenzen auch
belgien und die niederlande sind
betroffen in belgien kamen mindestens 18
menschen ums leben 19 werden noch
vermisst
die anwohner entlang der mars wurden
aufgefordert sich in sicherheit zu
bringen
auch in den niederlanden sind an den
flüssen maß und ruhe weite teile
überflutet rund 10.000 menschen mussten
allein in maastricht ihre häuser
verlassen
mehr reportagen hintergrundberichte und
interviews zur unwetterkatastrophe gibt
es direkt nach uns in einem zdf spezial
und auf dem laufenden halten wir sie
jederzeit auch online mit einem
live-blog in der zdf- heute- app jetzt
zu corona die bundesregierung stuft ab
sonntag griechenland die niederlande und
teile dänemarks als risikogebiete ein
wegen deutlich steigender
infektionszahlen und auch hierzulande
gehen die zahlen wieder hoch das robert
koch institut meldet 1456 neue fälle
innerhalb eines tages das sind 507 mehr
als vergangenen freitag 18 menschen
starben binnen 24 stunden
die sieben tage incidents steigt auf 8,6
sachsen hat die masken pflicht beim
einkaufen abgeschafft bei instanzen
unter 10
das gilt ab heute im gesamten freistaat
denn im moment liegen alle landkreise
und städte unter dieser schwelle
einen mund nasen schutz muss weiterhin
in bus und bahn sowie in medizinischen
einrichtungen getragen werden
in sachsen ist die impfquote niedriger
als in den meisten anderen bundesländern
auch deshalb kritisieren experten die
lockerung
wie gelingt es noch mehr menschen zur
impfung zu bewegen diese frage wird
angesichts der steigenden zahlen
intensiv diskutiert matthias fornoff ist
bei mir guten abend welche antworten
liefert das politbarometer zu diesem
thema naja die impfbereitschaft zu
fördern etwa durch finanzielle anreize
das lehnt eine große mehrheit ab anders
sieht es bei einer impfpflicht aus
zumindest für bestimmte bereiche für
beschäftigte im gesundheits und
pflegebereich sollte es eine impfpflicht
geben finden die meisten ebenso für
beschäftigte in schulen und kitas und
sollen für vollständig geimpfte alle
einschränkungen wegfallen
die allermeisten sagen nein masken
pflicht und abstandsregeln sollen auch
für geimpfte weiter gelten
lasst uns klug kurz auf die parteien
gucken wer hätte da wer hätte da die
besten chancen im moment die regierung
zu bilden
wir schauen erst mal auf die zahlen wenn
am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
dann käme die union auf 30 prozent plus
1 im vergleich zum vormonat spd 15
prozent auf plus 1 hf g10 fdp 10 linke 7
alle unverändert die grünen verlieren im
vergleich zu ihren werten im mai und
juni erneut 20 prozent minus 2 wer
könnte also realistischerweise eine
regierung bilden
schwarz grün hätte eine mehrheit eine
noch größere hätte ein dreier bündnis
aus union spd und fdp
alle zahlen können wir im heute journal
sehen um 10 oder jederzeit online
erhoffte erfreute dicke nach thüringen
dort sollte es eigentlich neuwahlen
geben im september zeitgleich mit der
bundestagswahl
weil im landtag derzeit keine mögliche
koalition eine mehrheit zusammenbekommt
doch jetzt ist auch dieser plan am
streit der parteien gescheitert
also bleibt erstmal die rot rot grüne
minderheitsregierung
die bisher von der cdu toleriert wurde
aus erfurt daniela sonntag notbremse vor
der abstimmung die fraktionsvorsitzenden
von rot-rot-grün verkünden am mittag
dass die landtagsauflösung vom tisch ist
damit keine neuwahlen thüringen im
september wir haben bis zuletzt um eine
mehrheit aus den demokratischen
fraktionen für neu eingeworben das hätte
60 stimmen für die auflösung des
landtages benötigt nach einer mathematik
haben wir sie leider nicht
es gab zu viele abweichler erst beim
stabilitäts partner cdu
dann war der linken regierungsfraktion
zu groß war nun die angst dass wieder
die afg einer entscheidungen erfurt mit
bestimmt denn zu tief sitzt immer noch
das kemmerich trauma von 2020
damals ließ sich der fdp-mann auch mit
afd stimmen zum ministerpräsidenten
wählen mit folgen weit über erfurt
hinaus
wir werden nicht ein parlament auflösen
mit der partei denn die parlamentarische
demokratie zutiefst verhasst ist doch
wie nun weiter
bodo ramelow aus minderheitsregierung
bislang gestützt von der cdu ein
stabilitätspakt den die cdu nicht
verlängern will
für unser cdu ist klar mit der
parlamentarischen sommerpause endet
jegliche zusammen
viel streit verlorenes vertrauen
zwischen den fraktionen wie der erfurter
landtag so zu entscheidungen finden will
bislang unklar
die wahlperiode geht offiziell bis 2024
und jetzt bist du dran norbert ihr den
olympischen sommerspielen in einer woche
geht es los mit der großen
eröffnungsfeier ganz ohne publikum
geisterspiel in tokio und eine alles
andere als begeisterte bevölkerung die
dem größten sportereignis der welt
skeptisch gegenüber steht die angst vor
steigenden corona zahlen ist groß
eigentlich sind die japanerinnen und
japaner stolz darauf dass ihr land
gastgeber ist für olympia doch wenn
sorgen um die eigene gesundheit und
zukunft überwiegen können auch bunte
plakate die stimmung nicht heben
heute knapp 1300 neue corona fälle tokio
hat gerade die höchsten zahlen seit
januar präsident thomas bach hat daher
einige mühe zuversicht auszustrahlen
heute besuchte er hiroshima der opfer
des atombombenabwurfs 1945 zu gedenken
jeder der hier war und diese erfahrungen
gemacht hat wird hiroshima wieder
verlassen als ein botschafter für den
frieden
eine bürgerbewegung hat rund 70.000
unterschriften gegen bach in hiroshima
gesammelt die friedensbemühungen nehmen
sie ihm nicht ab von einem pr auftritt
sprechen sie von einer missachtung der
menschen während der pandemie strapaziös
bleibt daher nicht nur die lange anreise
sondern auch die umstände vor ort auch
für die sportlerinnen und sportler aber
ich hoffe dass ich ein bisschen die lage
in den nächsten tagen entspannt es ist
ja meistens so wenn dann mal alles an
läuft und nichts dramatisches passiert
dann glaube ich setze ich auch bei allen
ein bisschen anspannung auch eine woche
vor den spielen bleibt nur die hoffnung
dass aus den zweifeln noch sowas wird
wie olympische begeisterung basketball
star dennis schröder wird der deutschen
nationalmannschaft nun definitiv bei
olympia fehlen grund sind die hohen
versicherungs anforderungen für den mbc
spieler ja drittletzte etappe der tour
de france von nur 1 nach liebe
und die gewann der slowene matej mavric
souverän sein zweiter tagessieg und
weiter im gelben trikot mit besten
chancen auf den gesamtsieg hd box ab
morgen dann die vorletzte etappe
zeitfahren und da entscheidet sich wer
die tour gewinnt vielen dank noch der
bange blick aufs wetter am wochenende
ziehen sich schauer und gewitter immer
mehr nach südosten zurück die details
hat gleich katja roll over mehr zur
hochwasserkatastrophe sehen sie im zdf
spezial direkt im anschluss und
natürlich auch im heute journal um zu
ihnen alles gute und bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen